نعود الى التطورات الانيه في الضفه
الغربيه تحديدا مخيم الامعري في رام الله
وهذه الصور المباشره الخاصه بالجزيره التي
تاتينا من هناك من مخيم الامعري اذا الذي
تقتحمه اعداد كبيره من الاليات والجنود
الاسرائيليين في هذه الاثناء التي تدهم
احياء فيه وقد ذكر مراسلنا قبل قليل بان
هناك اشتباكات وصفها بالعنيف والكثيفه في
المخيم في هذه الاثناء المخيم المحاصر من
كل مداخله وتمنع قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
دخول او
خروج اي شخص من المخيم وحتى السيارات
الاسعاف محمد خيري معنا من جديد يطلعنا
على تفاصيل ما يحدث في المخيم وتطورات
هناك
محمد نعم قبل دقائق فقط دخلت المزيد من
القوات الاسرائيليه الى احياء مخيم
الامعري شاهدنا المزيد من الحملات الجند
الاسرائيليه وربما تشاهدون حامله الجند
هذه التي تقف على مدخل المخيم من وراء
الجب العسكري الاسرائيلي الى الامام من
هذه المركبه هناك عدد كبير من المركبات
المشابهه من ناقلات الجند التي تحمل عشرات
الجنود الاسرائيليين الذين دخلوا الى مخيم
الامعري قبل قليل وهذا ايضا مشهد شاهدناه
قبل قليل ايضا دخلت قوات مشابهه لها في
العده والعتاد والحجم طبعا لذلك الان يدور
الحديث عن قوات
اسرائيليه كبيره ونسمع الان اصوات
انفجارات من داخل الاحياء الداخليه في
مخيم الامعري و علمنا ان قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي تحاصر مبنى وكذلك احياء داخل
المخيم وان تحاصر حي حي ابو حميد داخل
مخيم الامعري كما علمت
وكذلك هناك عدد من الاصابات في صفوف
الشبان الفلسطينيين يدور الحديث ايضا عن
اشتباكات تدور رحاها في هذه الاثناء داخل
ازقه هذا المخيم وحواريه بين الفلسطينيين
وقوات جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي التي تفض
تفرض على مخيم الامعري طوقا امنيا وكذلك
تحاصره من جوانبه كافه وتمنع الدخول
والخروج اليه كذلك كل يعني ما ما اعتدنا
عليه خلال تغطياتنا هنا في الضفه الغربيه
وخاصه بالقرب من المخيمات كل من يقترب من
المناطق المحاصره قد يعرض نفسه لاع اداء
وتنكيل من قبل قوات الجيش الاسرائيلي
ولذلك يبدو واضحا ان القوات الاسرائيليه
تحاول ابعاد الفلسطينيين من الاقتراب خشيه
من اندلاع مزيد من المواجهات ايضا يفيد
شهود عيان الان ان ثمه مداهمات لعدد كبير
من المنازل يدور الحديث عن حوالي 15 منزله
جرى مداهمتها من قبل قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في هذه الاثناء كما اخبرني
شاهد عيان ان قوات اسرائيليه ايضا تعتلي
اسطح بعض المنازل في المخيم وتنشر فرق
القناصه في على هذه الاسطح وتحاصر بعض
الاحياء التي تدور فيها الاشتباكات والتي
ايضا تجري فيها القوات الاسرائيليه عمليات
مداهمه لمنازل المواطنين الفلسطينيين في
طبيعه الحال يتضمن ذلك تخريب الممتلكات
وافساد كل ما يحتاجه ويعتاش عليه
الفلسطيني داخل منزله وثمت كما قلنا جرافه
كانت مصاحبه للقوات الاسرائيليه
والتي والتي تخرب سيارات الفلسطينيين
وتجرف
ايضا والتي تجرف ايضا الشوارع
في
المخيم يبدو ايضا يعني كما يخبرنا شهود
عيان ان ثمه حاله من التراجع لدى قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من بعض الاحياء في
المخيم
ولكنه ليس انسحابا كاملا من المخيم ولكن
شهدت قبل قليل قوات المشاه الاسرائيليه
وهي تحتشد قرب الاليات العسكريه ولكن لا
يمكننا الجزم بان ثمه انسحاب من داخل
المخيم خاصه اننا سمعنا قبل دقيقتين فقط
اصوات اطلاق الرصاص المستمر في داخل احياء
مخيم الامعري ما يعني ان الاشتباكات لا
تزال تدور داخل هذا المخيم وربما تكون
هناك عمليات انسحاب من بعض الاحياء ولكن
وقد تكون عمليات تمركز لاعاده الدخول الى
احياء اخرى في داخل مخيم الامعري اذا كما
قلنا هذه المشاهد تاتيكم مباشره نعم من
داخل مخيم الامعري و نشاهد ايضا مركبات
عسكريه تتجه الى طرق اخرى وتمنع السيارات
الفلسطينيه من الاقتراب كما تشاهدون في
هذه المشاهد الخاصه بقناه الجزيره من داخل
مخيم الامعري في محافظه رام الله والذي
يتعرض في هذه الاثناء الى اقتحام واسع جدا
في الحقيقه هذا ما شاهدناه في اعيننا هو
اقتحام كبير وليس مجرد اقتحام لذا المخيم
الان هناك انسحاب فقط لقوات المشاه من بعض
المناطق ولكن الاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه لا تزال تجوب احياء هذا
المخيم الداخليه ولا تزال تفرض طوقا وحصار
على ال المخيم من كافه جوانبه ايضا الى
جانب هذا الحصار دعني اقول الذي يفرد على
المخيم فهناك حصار داخلي يفرد على
البنايات هو ليس حصارا يعني الجندي لا يقف
على باب البنايه ولكن مجرد هذا الانتشار
الواسع لجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي داخل
مخيم صغير جدا وضيق جدا فهو يمنع
المواطنين الفلسطينيين من الخروج من
منازلهم ومن العمارات السكنيه يمكنكم الان
مشاهده هذه التحركات للقوات الاسرائيليه
هناك وصراخ
الفلسطينيين
مقابلهم اذا هذه يعني القوات الاسرائيليه
تترجل من هذه
المركبه العسكريه واوقفت مركبه
تابعه لمواطن فلسطيني ن